device number three is to measure
measure passion not progress so most of
us get an average of about 27,000 days
of life I think a good metric by which
you should live is to maximize the
number of those days that are filled
with a passionate pursuit of something
not by how much you've progressed
towards a particular goal because goals
are grounded in your comparison to other
human beings to something that's already
been done before passionate pursuit of
something is the way you achieve
something totally new and a quick
warning about passion again I'm a little
bit of Russian so maybe I romanticize
this whole suffering and passion thing
but the people who love you the people
who care for you like like I mentioned
your friends your family should not be
trusted accept their love but not their
advice parents since the
and others will tell you to find a
secure job because passion looks
dangerous
it looks insecure advisors colleagues
will tell you to be pragmatic because
passionate looks like a distraction from
the main effort that you should be
focusing on
and since society will tell you to be to
find balance work-life balance in your
life because passion looks unhealthy